wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some amazing
motivation from the one and only john
assaraf
[Music]
what if every day
when you woke up
okay
you did this you write out
okay
on a sheet of paper on your computer
all right i'm so happy and grateful for
the fact that i am now earning i'm so
happy and grateful for the fact that i
am now earning and put a number there
i'm now earning whatever let's say
you're making 10 000 whether it's a day
a week or a month i'm now earning 20 000
okay i'm not earning and then
in the very next step you started to see
yourself
earning that amount of money you started
to see yourself and how you felt you
start to see yourself
uh and how many people you would impact
you started to see yourself as you
upgraded your knowledge and your skills
and you developed you started to feel
proud and you started to feel
in
alignment with
making that amount of money okay so you
started to visualize why because
visualization is simulation and you
start to fire off the neurons in your
brain
right you start to fire off the neurons
in your brain the neurons that fire
together will wire together that's part
one
then
what would you need to believe what
would you need to believe
all right in order
to earn twice as much money what would
you need to believe about yourself
right what would you need to
um to think and then
what would you need to do that day
right that week that month
all right so in my trunk
uh when you set a goal like you just
said i'm sorry now running two trillion
dollar company when you set that goal
and you haven't built a million dollar
company your brain deletes it because it
it activates the uncertainty and fear
centers so set a goal that's just
outside of your comfort zone
all right just outside of your comfort
zone that
scares you a little bit but also
encourages you and inspires you so what
would you need to believe what would you
need to do what would you need
to think and then what skills would you
need to upgrade
whose help
would you need in order to make that a
reality so we go from
ideation or imagination we go from
ideation and imagination which is the
einstein part of the brain all right and
then we ask ourselves all those other
questions so that now we could put
a path towards that prime is i actually
you know have all my my life's vision
and purpose and my goals
on a laminated sheet in my bathroom
and so while i'm brushing my teeth i'm
priming my brain with what i wanted to
focus on what beliefs i want what goals
i wanted to accomplish
all of your vision your goals your
beliefs your habits are in your head
they're in your brain
and so why not prime it with what it is
you want instead of what it is you don't
want yes how do you grow if you're new
in business
and the answer is the more methodically
you can start your business from
thinking about
your marketing and sales first
meaning
how are you going to brand your product
or service so it stands out from the
competition number two
what is the one or two
primary method that you are going to use
to generate a stream of qualified leads
now
in the world of lead generation
you can be advertising on facebook on
instagram on linkedin on youtube you
could be doing blogs videos you could be
doing articles you could be doing
infographics and the list goes on and on
including direct mail
so the question is which one should you
be doing and the answer is
it depends now pay close attention
depending on your skill and depending on
your ability to invest money whenever
you're doing any type of marketing
what you're really doing
is you are looking to buy information to
see which channel
works best for your type of product or
business now
some products or services
don't warrant advertising because the
cost of advertising is way too high so
you may have to go to a direct selling
model but other products and services
deem you being able to advertise on many
of the social media channels and for
some of you radio and television but in
order to be
effective in marketing and sales what
you have to understand is marketing is a
science and an art and in order to get
better at marketing you're either gonna
have to do it yourself get help doing it
get it done for you
or don't do it now in the world of so
many options what you've got to discover
is this
who is your ideal avatar or client
profile that's question number one and
when you understand if it's a male or
female what age group they are when you
understand what is their socioeconomic
status when you understand where do they
go to find the solution that they're
looking for that your product or service
does for them
then you can start to put whether it's
non-paid content or paid content in the
flow of where they are
in order to create what i call is a
sales process and the sales process is
simply
a way of thinking about generating leads
qualifying the leads
converting them meaning getting them to
buy from you and then if they don't buy
from you then nurturing them until they
either buy from you or refer somebody to
you
all of this can be thought out in
advance and when you take the time to
work on your business instead of in your
business trying 500 different things
then you're able to quickly solve
the little riddle of being an
entrepreneur and that is getting leads
converting them and creating predictable
cash flow and profits
when we procrastinate in two out of
three cases
it's a protective mechanism it protects
us so there is something called the law
of secondary gains can somebody type
that in the law of secondary gains
and i'm going to give you two other laws
but the law of secondary gains
all right says this
that when we behave in a way like
procrastination yes we're not doing the
thing that we say we want to do need to
do or should do
because we don't want to do it
we're doing it because somehow there's
another
gain that we are getting
does that make sense so let me give you
an example a secondary gain might be
something like this let's say
i don't take action
on completing a project that i have
i don't take action on studying i don't
take action on something that i know i
want to do or should do
so i get the first gain by not taking
action because i get some kind of relief
right and the question is relief from
what
so what about this what about thinking
about procrastination like this in this
particular context
if i don't take action consistently is
it possible that i'm actually
having a secondary gain like i feel safe
i feel safe
can you feel safe in your comfort zone
can you feel safe
in the event that you take action let's
say your work is criticized if you take
action and you fail if you take action
and you're embarrassed or ashamed or
ridiculed or judged so can you see
that instead of being embarrassed
ashamed ridiculed judged or failing or
disappointing yourself again
it's easier not to take action
because you don't want to deal with the
embarrassment shame guilt rejection etc
think about this
are people afraid some people afraid of
public speaking
are people afraid of public speaking
right well some people are some people
but let's talk about the people who say
they're afraid of public speaking
maybe
they want to speak in public
but
in the event they do if they get on a
camera like this and they the thumb and
then they mess up and the wrong words
come out or they or they think that they
don't look really great and people are
going to embarrass them or make them
feel ashamed or ridicule them or judge
them if they think those are
possibilities isn't it easier to say i
don't want to publicly speak
so we don't publicly speak that's the
first game but the secondary gain is i
avoid
being embarrassed ashamed ridiculed
judged disappointed embarrassed etc does
that make sense so sometimes
procrastination
is because of a secondary gain
so here's what i want you to do does
this make sense first and foremost
everything that i teach you always is
based on the latest neuroscience okay
and
understanding how to get yourself to use
your brain better so the law of
secondary gains is saying that when i
procrastinating i'm getting a greater
benefit somewhere else as a result of
the procrastination what's the number
one reason we procrastinate
is it because we want to
have you ever heard of the law of
secondary gain so think about this for
just a minute when you procrastinate
is there a benefit
when you procrastinate is there a
benefit think of a secondary benefit
is it possible pay close attention
is it possible that when we
procrastinate
maybe
we're protecting ourselves
have you ever thought about that
when i procrastinate maybe i'm
protecting myself and so the question is
protecting myself from what
when i procrastinate maybe
i'm not doing what i need to do or want
to do i get that but maybe i'm also
protecting myself the question is
protecting myself from what
right so think about this let me uh let
me put a little meat around the bone for
you okay
when we procrastinate a secondary
benefit
could be
that we are
fearful of let's say being embarrassed
i'll give you a couple of examples so if
i take the action that i need to take or
want to take whether it's asking for a
raise whether it's
leaving my job and trying to find
something new leaving a relationship i'm
not happy in um
going across the room and asking a man
or a woman what their name is
starting you know a new career
doing something sometimes has
known and unknown consequences
associated with it so
if we are afraid that if we take action
and the action doesn't result
in the desired outcome that we want
is it possible
that the fear of failing or the fear of
disappointing yourself or the fear of
being embarrassed or the fear of being
ashamed or the fear of being ridiculed
or the fear of disappointing yourself
one more time or the fear of losing
money
is it possible that when your
subconscious mind okay is processing the
potential consequences
of the behavior
is it possible that as a protective
mechanism
we procrastinate is it possible that
hold on our 100 billion dollar bio
computer
100 billion by computer what i call is
the
frankenstein's monster part of the brain
right is it possible
that that part of the brain is causing
the behavior
we call
procrastination right so is it possible
that procrastination is
in many cases
a secondary gain mechanism
to protect us
so we want to do what we want to do the
behavior but our brain is always
processing what is the potential
negative consequence
now or in the future and if
we deem that there's any
chance of being embarrassed ashamed
ridiculed judged disappointed failure
loss
pain discomfort any of those
types of potential feelings potential
results
causes us to do what to put the brakes
on motivation the motive for the action
put the brakes on behavior the motor
cortex in the brain and then what do we
do
we then go do something else that we
feel is safer and easier for us
because
we already know what that behavior will
give us and usually we will move towards
something pleasurable something that's
common something that we've always done
listen if you don't feel like doing
something
once in a while
then you're human
but
like let me know if this resonates with
you and whoever's listening let me know
if it resonates with you do you agree
with this statement
in life you're going to either pay the
price of discipline
or you're going to pay the price of
regret
discipline weighs ounces regret waze
tons
that's jim rohn by the way and so
when you're sitting there and saying i
don't feel like it
my question for you is what do you not
feel like it more doing this little
thing
or living a life of regret
wow that's huge
right so let's create
a juxtaposition against what i don't
feel like doing
and let's
use contrasting to say
are you okay
with this being your character are you
okay with this being your life forever
are you okay with developing a lazy
habit and lazy disciplines are you okay
for the next one year three years five
years 10 years 20 years 30 40 years
having that as your modus apparanda and
your identity
if you're okay with that don't feel like
it don't do it but then don't complain
and don't want any more
but if you're not okay
with the short-term and long-term
consequences of that decision
then here's what i want you to say
i know i don't feel like it but
i will do just a little bit
love it now why just a little bit listen
i know the power of the mind when we
don't feel like it but i also know the
power of our brain when we say i know i
don't feel like it but i will just do
one minute
what does that do
now you develop a new pattern of hearing
and feeling i don't feel like it and
then you are in control saying i'm going
to override
that and i'm going to do a little
and so let me ask you a question just to
put this into perspective
can you jog a marathon right now that's
this is a question for everybody who's
listening can you jog slowly a marathon
right now non-stop 26.2 miles
most people say
no i can't jump 26.2 miles
but let me just prove something to you
let's say we made a minute i'm going to
continue where we started let's say we
made a commitment today you're out of
shape
you're lazy you don't feel like it you
can't run a marathon you don't know what
to do you don't know how to train you
don't know what to eat you don't know
how much to rest you don't know what
help you need but let's say
we committed
that one year from now
we're gonna jog a marathon together
slowly and safely
if today you made that commitment and
all you did was get up
put on your running shoes and moved in
your living room for one minute
and tomorrow you move for one minute and
the next day for one minute the other
day for one minute after seven days
you'd have seven minutes and you'd also
have
somebody who may have been lazy that
didn't want to
that didn't know what to do how to do it
when to do it why to do it now has
exercised for seven minutes now what do
you think that does to your self-image
and self-esteem hey
um i just did something every day for
seven days now maybe i have maybe i can
do more than i think i can now what if
you started watching videos on youtube
maybe reading a little bit or talking to
somebody who's run a marathon say hey
what did you do to exercise in months
one two three four five six seven what
did you do to eat what foods did you
stop what did you do for your sleep how
much rest did you get maybe i should
join a group of people who are beginner
beginner beginners and maybe in week two
you just did five minutes a day and in
week three it's 10 minutes a day and in
week four it's 30 minutes every two days
is it possible that if we made a
commitment
and we upgraded our knowledge and skills
and we got into the environment maybe of
some people that can help us and we can
help them stay motivated
is it possible and probable
that almost everyone one year from today
could slowly and safely jog a marathon
right so all that has to happen
is you have to make a commitment
to
not staying stuck
right now
all you have to do is get started and do
as little as possible to get in motion
why because an object in motion tends to
stay in motion newton's second law of
thermodynamics and an option an object
at rest has to stay at rest if you were
out of shape physical shape okay how
would you get back in shape like what
would you do
think let's be realistic logical if
you're out of shape you've been out of
shape you're overweight
you're not as healthy as you can be
right what would you do if you made a
commitment to be in shape okay right if
you were committed to being in shape
let's talk about physically right now
what would you do to break the pattern
the software
so
somebody says you could diet you can
exercise
uh you can sleep um well right get six
to eight hours of sleep so you reduce
your cortisol levels and reduce your
leptin levels so diet go on go into the
gym visualize motivate willie says start
gradually um right you can
you can create a vision board and see
yourself right in shape
right you can start with small steps you
can get an accountability partner you
can join a gym you can hire a coach you
can ask a
family member or friend if she or he
would like to you know start small so
you can develop the habits magic 321
right so what our habits habits are
automatic combinations of thoughts
emotions feelings sensations and
behaviors that are all automatic to do
without thought but to get to a habit
right to get to a habit we have to start
all right with how we think right
we have to continue with how do we feel
motivated or unmotivated well how do we
get motivated how do we stay motivated
then we need to know what are the
behaviors that we want to take so we
want to work
on an inner game
and an outer game so all of my students
for example all my private clients
whether i'm working with a ceo or an
athlete or a homemaker doesn't matter i
ask them to commit to 100 days
okay to develop a new
pattern
that they can reinforce
so do you think it's reasonable let me
ask you a question
do you think it's reasonable
to say to yourself
that i'm going to commit to 100 days to
give myself the best chances of a solid
foundation that i could build upon so
instead of thinking that i'm going to
change a result or change a habit that
i've had for 10 20 30 years in a weekend
or in a week or two or three that's just
unrealistic do you think that if we just
change the expectation
and we said okay
i'm going to do it fast
but i'm not going to do it so fast that
i don't sustain
sustain the thinking the emotions and
the behaviors so here's what i want to
ask you right if you're committed to an
outcome that you don't just want to
achieve and then stop
right
then why not commit to a process that
you can continue
and people will do things
for either a reason
a season or a lifetime a reason a season
or a lifetime here's what we know okay
let's say you've been earning a certain
amount of income for the last you know
10 years
all right within range and you want to
maybe double or triple your income
isn't it worth it
to be disciplined
to
sustainable change versus you know rapid
change that goes away
if we are creatures of habit
then why not get really good at develop
empowering constructive
positive habits
why not get good at upgrading our own
mental and emotional behavioral software
so that once we do it we can just
sustain it because we set a new
expectation for ourselves there's too
many people
okay
out there teaching you know fast food
thinking you know lose all the weight in
seven days well you're gonna gain it all
back because most of the weight you lose
is water
right
let's see how much money i can make this
weekend well that's great but you're not
going to sustain it because the habit is
not there
this is why
people who win the lottery lose it
within three years and people who lose
money that they've made it
gain it back within three years because
they have the neural pattern
of the behavior inner size number one is
called take six com the circuits
so there are two major circuits in the
human brain the parasympathetic nervous
system or circuit and the sympathetic
nervous system so when we have
a
disempowering experience a fear a stress
anxiety uncertainty self-doubt
the sympathetic nervous system has
kicked in
and basically um the neurochemicals of
cortisol epinephrine norepinephrine
adrenaline kick in and we just don't
like that feeling in a lot of cases
it also shuts down motivational centers
in our brain it shuts down our thinking
and imagination center in our brain and
so we're in a heightened state of
disempowerment and procrastination and
fear and the fight-or-flight thing you
were talking about earlier
kicks in so one of the first things to
do is whenever you feel you know anxious
angry stressed uncertain you take six
deep breaths in through your nose
and then out through your mouth but blow
out like you're blowing out through a
straw so in through your nose one two
three four and then pucker your lips a
little
and focus on the airflow coming out of
your mouth for four seconds five seconds
six seconds
when you do that just
six times
takes
less than one minute to a max of 90
seconds you actually deactivate
the sympathetic
circuitry
which causes us to have you know
elevated heartbeat
elevated blood pressure and it activates
the parasympathetic so in the stress so
you're frankenstein to your einstein you
got it so when frankenstein activates
right you're in a stress mode
and to deactivate the stress mode you do
take six com the circuits and that puts
you in the calm and respond mode so it's
stress and react calm and respond if you
want to double your income you might
also need to upgrade
your knowledge and your skills
to match the income that you want to
make
do you think that maybe
one of the four things you need is to
upgrade your knowledge and your skills
in order to
match the income that you want to make
would you agree
that for every
amount of income that you want to make
for
uh whether it's in business whether it's
in investing in the stock market whether
it's investing in real estate whether
it's selling your knowledge or skills
okay
to somebody else that you need to level
up your knowledge and skills to match
the income that you want to make i mean
that's the first way to upgrade your
brain to upgrade your income right so
what it takes to earn 20 000 a year is
different than what it takes to earn a
hundred thousand dollars a year is
different than what it takes to earn a
million dollars here or 10 million or a
hundred million would you agree
that a two by two rubik's cube
is easier to solve than a three
by three rubik's cube right well what if
the two by two represents the knowledge
and skill you need
for this income level let's just make
the metaphor uh for this income level
and then the
additional knowledge and skills and
upgrading
knowing the algorithm for three by three
because it's a little bit more complex
um you need to upgrade your knowledge
skills but what if you want to go to
a four by four uh and let's say this
represents uh 500 000 a year
right 500. oh that's not enough well
what if you want to go to a million
dollars a year right the algorithm
exists well what if you want to be a
billion dollar company
the complexities change and the
algorithms and the knowledge and skill
changes right and if you don't have the
knowledge and skill
then let me share with you what's
happening in your brain
if you don't have the knowledge and
skill
then there's a part of your brain called
the limbic system the emotional response
system that says hey
if i don't have the knowledge and skill
then
i'm going to be in a state of stress and
in a state of stress
right i'm going to deactivate my
motivational center and i prefer to stay
in my comfort zone instead of possibly
failing
and being embarrassed or failing and
being
ridiculed or failing and being judged or
failing and feeling like a piece of you
know what
so what happens
right so what happens is in the absence
of knowledge and skill we actually
activate specific circuits that
deactivate motivation and our desire to
behave in certain ways so we
procrastinate self-sabotage every day
invest one hour on upgrading your
knowledge and skill
every day invest one hour on upgrading
your knowledge and skill
in the area that will allow you to earn
more income now why an hour a day well
obviously we sleep for you know five six
seven hours a day um and you've got
another 18 or so hours a day so why not
one hour to upgrade knowledge and skill
when you do that do you think when you
upgrade knowledge and skill
you gain more self-confidence
when you gain more self-confidence does
that give you more certainty when you
have more certainty do you think that
might activate your motivational center
of course these are all circuits in your
brain so one of the things to consider
is if you upgrade your knowledge and
skills each day by one hour at the end
of one year that's nine nine
40 hour weeks nine 40-hour weeks imagine
if you and i went to school today
and we studied any topic
for
nine
40-hour weeks
that's
two and a half months of studying every
day something do you think you'd get
better at it when i analyze businesses
whether they're startups or doing a
hundred million dollars in revenue
doesn't make a difference
usually there's something in one of
those three or all of those three that
is missing
and so when we start to focus on
getting the inner game right plus what
you need to do
and then you do it
the results are pretty easy so here's
what i want you to ask yourself
are there people out there
all right that could buy your product or
service but you don't know how to reach
them
right is it possible that there's people
out there that need what you have your
product your service your knowledge your
skills whatever it is that you're
selling
offering to the marketplace is it
possible that you just don't know how to
reach them
so that means that it's a skill set
issue right
now
in 2021
we know how to do those things there
like i said earlier where i started
right the fact that there are two
billion people a day
online
means that there's more than enough
people to get in front of listen in the
old in the old days right
when we didn't have the internet we had
to advertise you know in the newspapers
postcards magazines radio television or
set up a store in a shopping center
but now just about every single business
okay
is online offering information content
to develop a relationship and rapport
with prospects and they're taking them
through a process yellow pages that's
right thank you
muse debbie debbie muse
right so yellow pages
so here's the thing one of the formulas
that you must figure out is where i
started before
traffic times conversion equals revenue
the added version to that
is traffic times conversion plus
repeat business and referrals equals
exponential revenue
traffic times conversion equals revenue
now traffic times conversion plus
referrals and repeat business equals
exponential revenue and so one of the
things that you need to be thinking
about okay and if this is the only thing
that you leave today i'm going to give
you a couple things number one is i need
to adapt i need to adapt to the market
and use all the tools available to me
but not use every one of them
i want you to ask yourself the question
i posed earlier is what has to happen in
order for me to just double or triple
the leads that i get
leads
the the prospects coming to see you
online or offline if you just focused on
that question
what has to happen in order for me to
double or triple my prospects or leads
and i'm not sure who said that you
picked up the answer virginia yeah this
is
this is my new york times best-selling
book the answer uh if anybody's read it
uh it is a new york times bestseller for
many many many years now one of the best
books on the inner game and outer game
of business
uh i put that back
over there
on my on my thing um but i didn't come
here to to sell you on my on my book i
want to give you information if anybody
wants to get the book on amazon for 15
or less it'll blow your mind and the lux
coast you're reading it now awesome so
when we understand there's already a
process in place
and we discover
how do we take our product or service
and create the marketing how many of you
are you good in marketing
are you good in marketing meaning i'm
not talking about branding
i'm talking about getting your product
or service with the right message
in front of the ideal client
if you're not good at marketing okay i
want you let me know are you good at
marketing yes or no so you're not good
at marketing
think about this if you're a business
owner
there's a couple of different hats that
you have to make sure are being taken
care of right in business if you're a
business owner with a product or service
you have to have somebody who's doing
the marketing right which is developing
your brand creating your messaging for
how you're gonna promote your product or
service to people who don't know you you
have to learn how to sell and selling is
doing something for somebody not to
somebody uh you need to learn how to
manage you need to learn how to either
develop products you need to learn some
of the technology needs that you have
there's a lot of different hats
that you have to wear
or you have to make sure that somebody
in your company
is wearing that hat right
and so
imagine if you're
needs surgery but you're not a good
surgeon what would you do
you'd have to find how do i get somebody
who could do the surgery so for those of
you who are not good at marketing or
sales which is the oxygen required for
any business regardless of how good your
product or service are
the question you want to be asking
yourself is this who can i hire to help
me
or who can i barter with to help me
who can i partner with to help me
do my marketing and sales if you're not
good at that so hire
partner
barter
or
defer payment to get it done because
without
marketing and selling
you really don't have a business and
those are skills that either you have
that you need to develop or you don't
have you're not good at you don't want
it but you still need to figure out as a
business owner how am i going to get it
done your job as a business owner is not
to do everything but to make sure that
everything that is oxygen and is
required gets done if your self-image
is not in coherence
with the goal that you want to achieve
you'll sabotage your success we
discovered that self-esteem if there's a
disconnect between our vision and goals
and self-esteem self-esteem will drag us
down procrastinate sabotage rationalize
those are the causes or the self-esteem
is one of the causes that holds us back
here's what i learned many many years
ago and i'm going to leave you with this
one of my mentors who is a billionaire
said john i don't want you to get
stronger at your weaknesses
i want you to get stronger at your
strengths
i want you to manage your weaknesses
manage my weaknesses i said to him how
do i manage my weaknesses he says you
practice radical honesty about what
you're strong in
create a plan to get better and you are
radically honest what you're not good at
and you find people to help you
who are good at that now here is what
i'm going to leave you with
he said to me
hire people
who play
at things you have to work at
hire people who play
at things
you have to work at and i can fill in
the blank like i did before say you can
hire bar to defer payment or partner
with people who play at the things that
you have to work at
all right so if you're not good at
certain parts of business that's okay
you need to admit you're not good at it
but your job as the ceo of your business
is to figure out how am i going to get
that done
by asking better questions you get
better answers but by saying i'm not
good at that i don't know how to do that
i don't like that you're reinforcing
your patterns in your brain
you're reinforcing patterns in your
brain that are going to make you worse
at it
so instead of putting yourself down lift
yourself up instead of coming up with
stories and reasons and excuses why you
can't focus your brain on how you will
because you must you gotta clear through
the noise of negativity out there stay
positive because
people are buying people are buying
people are buying right now right now
and that means that there is more
business available to you but you have
to manage your mindset upgrade your
skill set and then make sure that you're
taking the right actions in the right
order at the right time fear is fear
something that you should fear
no
i want you to imagine is you're driving
down the street in your car
and a light pops up on the dashboard
a light pops up
um have you ever taken a hammer and hit
the light because you don't like the
light
of course not that would be silly right
what if the light on the dashboard was
just a signal maybe you're low on tire
air
air pressure maybe you're missing air or
water in your windshield wiper maybe the
back trunk door is open
isn't
the signal in your car
just for you to be aware that maybe
something is wrong or something needs
attention
is it possible that if we stop thinking
of fear as the enemy fear is one of your
biggest friends why well when you
understand how did this organism
okay develop and how
does it keep us alive
it pays attention to things okay in your
external world triggers from your
external word that could cause your
death or destruction it causes you to do
what when there is a potential
threat
predator or threat at the door
it lights up the fear signal sends
cortisol epinephrine or norepinephrine
into your bloodstream so you either know
how to fight it you run away or you
freeze hoping that the predator will go
away
so when your brain
every brain
gets this signal
that there is a threat
at the door
it sends a signal
in the form of a neurochemical that you
feel
now if somebody
feels this threat in their body but they
don't know how to manage the emotion we
call fear
let's say there's a fear that you have a
failure and what it might mean to your
family what what about a fear of losing
money and not having enough to pay the
rent the mortgage or for retirement what
if there's a fear of trying something
and then it not working out and you're
embarrassed or ashamed or ridiculed or
rejected or judged oh my god if you
judge me then you're going to reinforce
my low self-esteem of myself and then
holy [ __ ] then who am i you understand
what's happening in the circuits i'm
just describing
so when our brain has
this fear circuit activated do you think
the fear circuit causes you to go oh hey
let's take action anyway
or do you think it goes hi alert hi
alert hi alert be aware what's going on
what if you fail what if you succeed
with succeed and fail
whenever that circuit is triggered
motivational circuit shuts down whenever
that circuit is activated your thinking
circuits shuts down all the blood flow
goes into a part of your brain to help
you do what possibly run away protect
yourself
it's a protection mechanism but here is
what i want you to remember
this automatic trigger and circuit has
been evolving for millions of years but
your specific experiences since you were
born in the modeling experiential
and the
um and the imprinting years caused you
to have
beliefs
about things some empower you some
disempower let me give you an example
okay let me give you an example
when i say the word
or let me give you a different uh same
example with just a little different
story
if i say to you that i'd like to take a
big snake about five feet long and let
it slither across your arm and around
your neck and it's a python
how many of you go oh wow that would be
great
versus how many of you are going oh my
god let me run away get get it off of me
just just think of a snake slithering on
you and curling itself around your neck
how many of you are like run
versus oh my god that would be great can
you take a picture of me with it so i
put on social media
so is it really the snake
that is the threat
or is it
your concept in your brain the meaning
that you have associated with a snake
that is activating for some of you the
reward center
and for others the fear center same
stake stain stimuli there isn't even a
snake here i just add you think about it
right and it triggered that fierce
circuit for some reward circuit for
others so it's never about the thing so
when we have fear
of being embarrassed ashamed ridiculed
judged uh fear of disappointing
ourselves fear of failing if you're
succeeding there's 50 different types of
fears we automatically trigger
the circuit
that does what stops our action taking
as much as people think you know the why
is logical so we choose what we want
logically and some emotion
our why activates the limbic system of
the brain the emotional center of the
brain
if it's a why let's say for us or our
family then it's a good reason why but
what if it's a y that's even bigger than
that and it's to help mankind
now the y becomes a little bit more
spiritual now the why becomes even a
little bit more instinctual because we
are all connected and when i help
me and i help you i help we and us
and that is a much bigger reason than
just
me
and we will do more for others and for
humanity if we know that our life has
purpose and meaning
and so now we're activating different
parts of our brain so we're activating
logical part of our brain instinctual
part of our brain intuitional part of
our brain emotional part of our brain
the motor cortex of our brain the visual
cortex of our brain now we've got our
whole brain involved in helping us
achieve what we want and are destined to
achieve when you take action
how do you feel when you procrastinate
how do you feel positive or negative do
you think you're reinforcing
a negative pattern if you keep
procrastinating and you think you
reinforce a positive pattern when you
take one little micro action even when
you don't feel like it well
one of them releases stress hormones
when you don't take action because you
know you're not taking action but the
other one
releases dopamine
and if you tell
yourself if you tell others if you share
then not only are you activating your
reward center in your brain dopamine you
actually start to get addicted to taking
inspired positive action even when you
don't feel like it here is something to
consider when we are talking about
procrastination
just think of it as a behavior and my
job your job is to interrupt the
behavior ever so slightly and then
create and reinforce a new behavior you
every one of you that's listening is
brilliant genius
but ignorance just means i don't
know guess what your job is find the
[ __ ] out
because ignorance will spoil and kill
your dreams it'll spoil and kill your
potential and you'll feel like there's
something wrong with you because all
around you're going to see people are
succeeding
way ahead of you and you're wondering
like what's wrong with me what am i
doing that's not right
the answer is you just don't understand
you know i keep these jigsaw these
rubik's cubes on my desk
um there are people who can take this
rubik's cube and in about seven seconds
they can solve it behind their backs
while they're blindfolded there are
people that will solve this eight by
eight
cube in about i think the world record
right now is about 12 hours uh to get
this done there are
billions of combination and possible
moves here and there's quintillions of
combinations here why am i showing you
this because it's all about pattern
recognition if you understand
how to recognize the pattern how to get
you know um four of the colors onto one
side that's the beginning of the pattern
well guess what success is a pattern
being healthy is a pattern being wealthy
is a pattern being a great relationship
is a pattern being
all of it it's a pattern and if you
understand you learn the pattern for
success there's a thought pattern
that'll help you achieve success there's
an emotional pattern that'll help you
achieve success and there is absolutely
unequivocally a behavioral pattern that
when you do this and that
you have a predictable result
almost every single time what's neural
linking um in the neuroscience field
there's a statement it's uh it goes like
this the neurons that fire together
wire together
so what does that mean
well it means that for you know let's
say 58 years of my life or maybe not 58
but maybe you know 56 years of my life
i've been brushing my teeth so i have a
very strong pattern of brushing my teeth
and i associate brushing my teeth with
having white teeth clean teeth a nice
smile
fresh breath breath right so so right so
there you go that you know you you just
recited a commercial right
um
and so
now i'm taking what i want to achieve a
new belief a new habit a new vision new
goals and now i'm linking it and
connecting the neurons that have been in
my brain for 58 years so when i'm
brushing and priming my brain and i have
a positive association with brushing
now i'm linking everything that i want
into a network that already exists
[Music]
right and if we want to get a little bit
further
now what if i had my favorite color
there too and what if i had my favorite
number there too what if i always had a
picture of my favorite animal there that
gives me these awesomely powerful
emotions
the neurons that fire together wire
together so what if i associated my
favorite number and color and power
animal or gentle animal with new beliefs
that i want to have do you think it
would be possible to wire those new
beliefs faster into the brain yes yes
that's what innercise is all about is
learning these little
smart
mental and emotional techniques to
create confidence certainty empowerment
focus awareness
that leads to the behavior
that gives you the results you want at
the end of
your day or week do you ever find
yourself
worried or frustrated because no matter
how much effort you put in to work and
no matter how hard you work your
financial situation
and your financial future may never seem
to be improving you might be finding
yourself living paycheck to paycheck
right now with not a lot of breathing
room and i would imagine no
discretionary income or even time to
spend on the little things that really
would make your life more enjoyable well
what i can share with you
is you're not alone that's number one
and in most cases
the real problem
is not your current circumstances
what the real problem is that most
people repeat the same
patterns of thought
and behaviors over and over again
and that is the cause
of what more of the same results but
they are looking for different results
and so today i'm going to show you how
to break that pattern break that cycle
now you see when you think of your
results your results are effects and so
the question is effects of what
and the answer is your results are all
effects of what you believe to be true
about yourself what you believe to be
true that is possible
and
it also comes down to what are your
daily habits now
if you think about what you believe and
if you think about your habits that is
what is causing the effect that you may
not like right now and so a simple
logical thing to do would be to
understand that if i could change my
beliefs about what was possible and what
was possible for me specifically and i
could create more empowering habits
then my result will change
and what i love to focus on having done
an enormous amount of brain research
over the last 10 years
is something called your inner game
and your inner game
is comprised of obviously your beliefs
your attitude your perceptions how you
see the world
and your inner game is also comprised of
what causes you to take action
and so let me share just a little story
with you that may help you understand
what i mean
about two years ago i was at a seminar
and when i got off the stage this woman
started walking towards me and i could
see she was somewhere in her you know
50s maybe early 60s she looked nice she
was a vibrant woman she was walking
right towards me and i saw tears
streaming down her eyes
and when she got through the crowd
for a moment i thought that maybe there
was something wrong but she actually had
tears of joy in her eyes
and when i met her her name was joni
sanderson and this was in perth
australia and she came up to me she said
thank you so much and i go well for what
she says well
about a year ago i heard you speak about
beliefs
and habits and mastering my emotions and
really working on my self-worth and she
said to me that she was a caregiver
and that she loved helping families who
needed
extra assistance for their aging parents
or for their children who may need some
additional help in the home so she was a
wonderful caregiver but she was living
on a widow's pension of about 12 000
aussie dollars a year and so she really
didn't have enough money to be able to
take the care of her grandkids that she
wanted to to be able to take her
children on a vacation and so i shared
with her why do you think that you're
only earning twelve thousand dollars a
year and she said i don't know and when
i shared with her that she possibly
believed that that's what she was worth
and she said to me i think i'm worth
more i said well you might be able to
declare that you're worth more but if at
a deeper level
of your brain you have this feeling that
maybe you're not smart enough or not
good enough or not worthy enough
that is what is going to drive your
behavior
and so what i helped joanie do
prior to her coming to me and being in
gratitude was i helped her recognize
that beliefs drive behavior
beliefs drive emotions habits drive
behavior and in order to change your
results living paycheck to paycheck
being stressed out worrying about your
future or even your present
circumstances right now
why not focus on working on the neural
patterns the beliefs and habits that are
nothing more than patterns in the brain
that drive 96 to 98 of your behavior and
so she started to work on what i call a
belief and habit modification program
and while she did this she started to
see herself in a different light she
started to feel more confident more
certain and more empowered and what i
can share with you is she at that moment
told me that she went from making twelve
thousand dollars a year as a widow's
from a widow's pension and living
paycheck to paycheck
to being able to charge for her services
as she was making 75 000
a year people are focusing on all the
reasons why it's hard and difficult
and they're not focusing on remembering
that there are hundreds of millions of
people online every single day actually
2 billion a day are online
so you have to expand your horizon to
what is
and focus on what can be now
somebody type this in right now if you
can i'm going to give you a formula that
has helped me build five multi-million
dollar companies from scratch
to billions in sales a year okay are you
ready here is a magic formula for you
here's the magic formula
traffic times conversion or prospects
times conversion equals revenue
prospects times conversion equals
revenue
traffic times conversion either one
prospect so
the company the person who has the
product or the service
that gets in front of the most amount of
people with the right
offer let me repeat the company the
person
that gets in front of the most amount of
people
with the right offer makes the most
amount of money
so here is my question for you right now
are you getting your product or service
in front of people in your local
marketplace
in your national marketplace or online
right so if you are not waking up every
day
trying to figure out how do i get my
product or my service and what i'm
offering people in front of more people
either through advertising either
through
networking either through joint ventures
either through content either through a
variety of different means
you're going out of business because
there's more than enough people online
or offline i'm giving you an option it
doesn't matter even if you have a store
a stall a kiosk
even if you're selling your stuff online
it doesn't make a difference you have to
be focusing on how do i get more people
to see what i have to offer and then how
do i create an offer that is so good
that the people who want it and need it
buy from me
if you're not waking up thinking about
that
it's very hard to build your business
now if you can go back and tell your 18
years old what would you like to tell
him you don't need to be so afraid of
making mistakes you don't need to be so
afraid
of looking dumb you don't need to be so
afraid of not having the knowledge of
the skills
there are ways there are teachers there
are books there are coaches there are um
there's more information available for
free today
okay than at any time in the history of
our species if you're really committed
there's a way people will help you but
if you're not committed you'll never
find a way and nobody can help you
because you're not prepared to help
yourself
limiting beliefs if we have constructive
positive empowering beliefs
we move forward and take action but when
we have a limiting belief like i'm not
good enough i'm not smart enough i'm not
worthy i'm not skilled i'm too young i'm
too old i'm too white i'm too black i'm
too asian caucasian i'm this or i'm that
i'm not enough of this i'm not enough of
that
where are our beliefs
right we have two types of beliefs we
have conscious beliefs that we can
declare and then we have subconscious
beliefs as well which ones are the more
powerful of the two
mike edwards says subconscious beliefs
right
mike
says subconscious beliefs were you born
with any beliefs like if you were a
neuroanatomist
okay if you're a neuroanatomist if you
were to look in the brain
where would you find your beliefs the
positive the negative ones the good ones
the challenging ones the constructive
destruct where would you find them
what are they like what are they
like what are they
aren't those patterns
that have been reinforced based on what
we learned in childhood aren't those
patterns that our parents gave us our
teachers our brothers our sisters our
neighbors
right didn't we
develop our beliefs
through the imprinting years zero to
five or six the modeling years five or
six to you know seven or eight and then
the um the um um
experiential years
right all the way from birth to 25 26
when our brain was pretty plastic and we
developed these beliefs about
what to believe
we weren't born with any they're nothing
more than neural patterns in the brain
now how many of you have heard the word
neuroplasticity
neuroplasticity
right what is neuroplasticity
neuroplasticity
is the scientific fact that our brain
is plastic
right what does that mean it's not like
plastic like this brain
it means that we have brain cells
right so the brain cells okay there's a
cell
there's an axon okay or a body then
there's dendrites at the end right and
there's synaptic gaps in between the
brain cells so those brains have
potentiality and let's say we are told
that you're not good enough you're not
smart enough you're not worthy you'll
never amount to much you're too young
you're too old you don't have enough
knowledge you don't have enough skill if
those patterns
are created and those neurons are active
and releasing those neural chemicals
from a receptor or from a
ascending neuron to a receptor neuron
and that happens often enough that
neuron structure or pathway
becomes more solid just like
developing a highway system in a city
and the
pathways that are active and reinforced
when we are young
become the default pathways just like
the highways and the roads that you take
every single day to go to the stores you
take
now if it's true
that our neural pathways are not fixed
but the pathways that are easy to run
across okay or to fire the signals okay
are the ones that are dominant
is it possible
to let go of the limiting destructive
disempowering beliefs
that somebody else gave us for the most
part or we experienced
is it possible that through
conditioning programming deliberately
choosing our beliefs
and reinforcing new neural pathways we
can
create new neural pathways
right
so
if a neural pathway can be created and
neural pathways can be deactivated
then why not deliberately and
consciously evolve yourself when
you figure out
some of the math and then you ask
yourself okay
how am i gonna get my product or service
knowledge or skills that i'm selling
whatever it is that you're selling how
do i get that
in front of the right prospects i'm
gonna keep coming back and forth either
online or offline
online or offline how much do you think
achieving business success is an inner
game
thing
do you think that that it's a
combination of winning the inner game
and also winning the outer game of what
you need to do you and i own the most
powerful biocomputer in the whole
universe
that can help us achieve our goals
faster and easier than ever before but
if we're focusing on why we can't
if we're not focusing on knowing the
numbers if we're not focusing on
understanding how do we take
our product or service
and create marketing
and a selling process to get it in front
of people
then we're missing
the syntax the process to achieve the
success that we want so in the absence
of knowing we default
to our highest level of training
knowledge and skill so now that you know
you don't know because you've heard me
talk about it now you have awareness
do you know how you will know
is when you apply what i just shared
with you
and you have the visceral experience
that reinforces a neural pattern of just
knowledge with behavior knowledge with
behavior equals experience
reading a book gives you awareness it
doesn't give you knowledge
the knowledge comes from the application
and getting the feedback loops of all of
the sentence all of the senses
integrated into a pattern and if you
reinforce
what you know with what you do you end
up
with results 2021
and there's 108 or so billion humans
that have walked on planet earth
since the beginning of our time as a
species here on earth
everything that we want to achieve for
the most part
99.5 of what we want to achieve in
health wealth relations career business
uh fun experiences uh spirituality it
has already been
achieved by others and there's already
blueprints for what we need to think how
to manage our feelings what we need to
do how to develop habits so all the
how-to that almost every one of us needs
is already here but you will only go
after and find and apply all those
things
if you're committed to yeah so make a
commitment to trading your life for what
you love
and for training your life for what will
make you feel phenomenal and then go and
find the teachers and and the other
people that are on the same path uh
looking to achieve those goals because
together if we help each other we can
achieve the goals faster and easier than
ever before the law of bigger fears
states this do you agree
that there is um a way to frame things
that are more painful
if you give things certain meaning so
let me explain the law of bigger fears
let's say you're procrastinating
on
a project on
anything doesn't make a difference can
you put your uh something that you're
procrastinating in the chat right now so
put whatever it is that you're
procrastinating
okay uh right now if you can all right
put something in the chat of what you're
procrastinating right now let me share
with you the law of bigger fears so we
talked about the law of little actions
we talked about the law of secondary
gains but let's take a look at anything
that you are procrastinating right now i
want you to write out okay and you don't
have to do it
right now but
if you ask yourself
what
am i
gaining ben how am i gaining by
procrastinating so i feel safe i feel
secure
i don't have to expend energy etc also
next to that i want you to write down
what is the cost of procrastinating
what's the cost of procrastinating like
this
on your self-worth and self-esteem
on your income on your relationship on
your self-image of how you see yourself
on your self-trust so if and when i
procrastinate the cost to me
is more than just the completion of the
goal but the cost to me
is loss of self-respect the cost to me
as i reinforce a pattern of
procrastination the cost to me is i
repeat patterns that i reinforce the
cost to me what is the cost to you of
procrastinating and here's what we can
do
if you make the cost to you
bigger
than the reward you're getting for not
doing it
let me repeat that if you make the cost
of not doing it the bigger fear the
bigger cost
greater
than the cost or i'm sorry
that the reward you're getting
then now we have what's called is a
contrast frame
not doing this
gives me you know this which we know we
get but not doing this also costs me
this and reinforces this so now you say
not doing it i get these rewards but
here is what the cost is of staying in
my job michelle here's what the real
cost is on my income my self-worth my
self-esteem my children my spouse my
significant other
and if you believe and agree with me
that whatever
behaviors we reinforce we become
whatever behaviors we reinforce we
become why because of something called
automaticity in the brain
once we reinforce a pattern the pattern
then moves into a subconscious automated
sequence so there's no
thought involved in repeating the
pattern because it's easy and it doesn't
require any very little energy so when
we're talking about the law of bigger
fears the law of bigger costs
now we can use a contrast frame and our
brain is great at avoiding the bigger
pain
did you hear what i just said your brain
my brain is great at avoiding the bigger
of the two pains
and
since we do more to avoid pain than we
do to gain pleasure
if we're procrastinating because we're
gaining some kind of safety and pleasure
our brain will move away from the
greater of the two and the greater the
two is moving away from the bigger cost
there are a variety of different ways to
find ways to remove the darkness we can
read
we can go to youtube and watch videos we
can be on social media we can join
groups we can be part of masterminds we
can hire a coach we can go and work for
somebody you know who knows how to do
what you want to learn how to do and so
the first part though is to become
resourceful in the absence of resources
i'll give you an example mr brown says
i'll be your your mentor your guru and i
said awesome and the next thing he said
to me says well i need you to move from
montreal to toronto i said what
i don't know anybody in toronto i said i
don't have any money to get an apartment
i don't have a car i don't have you know
i don't have a job he says well you
don't need money a car an apartment or a
job first you need to make the decision
then you figure out how to get all the
rest yeah i said i know but you don't
understand
i left high school in grade 11. i have
60 dollars in the bank he says that's
okay says make the decision then you
figure out how so i said
well maybe i could move in with my
brother my best yeah you can move in
with me short term sleep on the sofa
because it's only a one bedroom
apartment that i live in and uh so i
ended up moving to toronto
and then right after that um
at the same same
sentence the same lunch that i had with
me said and i need you to enroll in the
real estate school um that cost 500 and
it starts on april the 20th and this was
in 1980 just to give you an example oh
i said
you want me to go back to school i left
school at grade 11. i failed english i
failed math i'm terrible school and i
need 500 i only have 60 dollars in the
bank account
i understand but first you make the
decision
and then you figure out how i said mr
brown
i don't have any money like i can't make
the decision you know to go into school
he says oh yes you can he says many
people
think that you have to have the tools
the knowledge the skills the resources
before you make the decision and he said
you know john f kennedy made a decision
to put a man safely on the moon and
return back to earth before we even had
the technology to be able to do that he
says
average people look at their current
circumstances and their past and they
allow that to dictate what they do or
don't do he says highly successful
people create a vision for what they
want and then they use their powerful
brain to figure out how they can because
they must
so i said
fine i'll find the money well my brother
then said well i can lend you 100 bucks
my mother lent me some money my sister
lent me some money three weeks later i
moved to toronto took the real estate
course five weeks later i passed the
real estate test because i studied every
day and he showed me how to and so in
five weeks i moved to another state i
found the money for a course i didn't
have money for i passed the test even
though i thought i wasn't very smart i
became a licensed real estate agent
all because
i made a commitment to doing it even
though i didn't know how even though i
didn't have the resources the financial
or non-financial resources
so one of the greatest lessons he shared
with me
is vision comes first
goals come second
strategies of how you're going to
achieve them come third if you take a
look at um you know um dr j and you take
a look at vince carty take a look at
dwyane wade take a look at any of the
players today lebron
they studied the patterns
of other great players and that's what
is really fun is i mean that's the fun
i'm having now is
i know
uh that if i gave a hundred people
the blueprint of what to do
one might do it
but if i trained a hundred people's
brains to focus on what i want them to
focus on i train them how to manage
their emotions
and i gave them
a blueprint of what to do i get 60 to
take action and follow through
and you may ask how do i know this
because i know when i used to sell our
coaching programs for five ten twenty
thirty fifty a hundred thousand dollars
when we didn't do the mindset training
and the emotional management training
the success of our clients was maybe
five or six percent and when we did
include the mindset
the emotional management and the skill
sets
sixty-two percent of our clients started
to achieve phenomenal success oh why
that makes you cry
the deeper you can get this
um and deeper you can not be afraid to
go there
and say yes i matter and i and i can
make a difference in my life and my
friends or kids or husband or wife and
family and community and mankind
that that that is what inspires you yes
right it's spirit within you is
expressing itself that way versus doing
things that expire you when you minimize
who you are
you're expiring your spirit wow
versus doing things that that inspired
that allow spirit to express itself more
fully spirit is always for fuller
expression and expansion of itself
right but we get these disempower
expiring beliefs and habits and
perspective and perceptions from
ignorant people that we grew up around
not because they were bad people they
just didn't know they didn't know any
better they didn't know any better and
now we know better
and so if we know better let's do better
feel better and be better and give
better and
and that's what it's all about let's say
you ask yourself a question
and you say to yourself
i don't know
say i don't know have you ever done that
am i the only one that sometimes when i
ask a question i go i don't know
um
then i ask myself i understand
but if i did know what could it be
so i want to go layer by layer by layer
to ask better questions the better
questions i ask the more my brain will
look to solve the answer won't it
right so i ask really good questions of
my brain and if i ask myself why am i
procrastinating i don't know say well if
i did know
uh what would it be i don't know
well could i go on to google and find
out why i procrastinate yes am i willing
to sure when right now
right if i go down another path if i
don't know
is it possible that somebody else knows
the answer to this is there a book that
the answer is in is there a youtube
video is there an instagram post is
there something on pinterest yeah is
there something
somewhere
online that i can find an answer to my
question if i keep saying i don't know
so the answer is of course the answer's
there it's 2021 the middle of 2021 of
course the answers are here the answer
here for how to lose weight and keep it
off the answer here on how to double
your income in the next 12 months the
answers are here for how to leave a job
that you hate and get a new one that you
love the answers here for how to start a
business the answers here
for how to put a rocket ship on mars the
answers here for how to be um
spiritually connected the answer is the
answers are here so is it possible
that
maybe we haven't learned to be great
question askers
and if it's possible that this
biocomputer
always finds the answer based on the
questions that we're asking so if you
ask yourself you know why can't i ever
achieve this
your brain's going to go let me show you
why you know why is this so hard well
i'll show you why you know how come i
can't figure it out those are shitty
questions
ask questions whereby the answer means
you're moving forward did you hear that
ask questions whereby the answer you
give yourself moves you forward so
you're never stuck finding the answer to
the problem you find the answer to the
solution did you hear that don't find
the answer to the problem or the
obstacle find the answer to the solution
what has to happen in order for me to
take action whose help do i need to take
action what do i need to learn what do i
need to start what should i stop why
must you grow your business why must you
can you give me one answer
why i must figure this out
i'm gonna tell you why this is important
from a brain perspective okay not why i
should
why must you
figure this out why must you all right
if you want to build a million dollar
business that has profits of two three
four five hundred thousand dollars if
you want to build a 500 000 business
that has profits of one or two hundred
thousand dollars here's what i want you
to understand when you set a goal to
achieve what you want you're using this
part of the brain right and many of you
know that's the specialty that i love to
talk about is the neuroscience of the
success
but you also have to get the limbic
system the emotional part of your brain
activated when we come up with a why
that is bigger than the stories the
reasons the excuses and pay close
attention
when we come with a why that is bigger
than the stories the reasons and the
excuses that are holding us back now we
will then
master change instead of mastering
disappointment did you get that
you have to come up with a reason why
you must upgrade your knowledge your
skills your beliefs your habits and your
behaviors or
you will
find it easier to master disappointment
versus mastering change question should
be why am i having a hard time making
the decision first and the answer is
because of fear
so i fear that if i make the decision
and i fail
then i'm a failure i fear that if i make
the decision and it doesn't work out
then i'm going to be disappointed i fear
that if i'm disappointed and maybe i
disappoint you then i'm going to be
embarrassed or ashamed or ridiculed or
judged or
worse yet rejected everybody understands
you can exercise to strengthen your
muscles your organs
your ligaments
but have you ever considered that you
can inner size your core neuro muscles
so what if we said that focus
is a neural muscle
and you can learn how to focus on how to
do something versus how not to do
something what if awareness was a neural
muscle and you could be aware of the
negative and the positive what if you
could be aware of emotions that cause
feelings
and some feelings i want to move away
from and some feelings i want to move
towards is it possible
that my habits are just a cluster of
neural muscles that have been reinforced
and i could learn how to
delete or get rid of disempowering
habits and if i understand how to inner
size do mental and emotional techniques
and some physical work i can strengthen
new habits
is it possible that our beliefs
our neuro muscles and i have some that
are weak and some that are strong and
it's possible based on the latest
neuroscience to create a new self image
that overrides an old self-image so our
self-image is kind of like a self-image
neural muscle that holds itself in place
and we walk around like you know like a
like a we have a um a frame around our
self-image we take it everywhere we go
well what if we could set aside our old
self-image and create a brand new one
with more confidence more certainty more
personal power
well
we can do that through behavior of
course and taking inspired action and
gaining more confidence and certainty
but we can also do that for example by
visualizing ourselves taking action by
visualizing feeling the fear and doing
it anyway and
one of the sentences that i love in the
in the world of visualization is in the
human brain visualization
is simulation
and when we practice simulations
that are new beliefs new habits new
self-image
practice makes permanent
[Music]
so if we understand how our brain
our neural muscles are formed what if we
just said okay how do you build let's
say a bicep muscle let's say it's weak
it's very very weak well let's say you
just did this
every day for 10 days and you just
squeezed at the top it would get
stronger right right well what if i took
a one pound weight the next week and i
did this it would get stronger right
right and what if i did three pounds
then five pounds then 10 pounds it might
take me 90 days but if i can only do my
arm right now
and 90 days worth of practicing made my
biceps stronger
what if i did 90 days of practicing in
here
[Music]
now i can practice in here and i could
do this and all the research shows
that whatever we practice we make
permanent and whatever is permanent that
we reinforce becomes fixed
[Music]
so maybe we have some beliefs that are
fixed that we just need to replace maybe
we have some habits they're
disempowering us we just need to replace
them maybe we have a self-image
challenge that is just not healthy
and we just need to replace our
self-image because we weren't born with
any fears we weren't born with any
beliefs we weren't born with a
self-image we weren't born with any of
the things that are holding us back
so inner size is really about how to use
mental and emotional techniques
that you back up with taking action a
little bit at a time
that over 30 60 90 180 days a year you
strengthen it and you have more
confidence more certainty more personal
power so now your self-image self-worth
and your identity matches the destiny
you want i was born into the jewish
faith but i don't i know i celebrate
holidays with my kids but i'm not
religious and
the reason i say god is because i
believe that within me
is god
within
you and everybody watching or listening
is god
the
intelligence that lives
breathes
is in everything and in everyone
is where all of the knowledge and
intelligence is in the universe
and by tapping in
by using our electromagnetic switching
station called our brain
into the field of all knowledge and
intelligence and all of the
information that exists in the field of
intelligence i have access to the entire
congress of libra or library of congress
for everything ever
that has been created or will be created
so
that's the source of all supply
that's source i want to learn from do
you know why right now is the easiest
time in the world to grow your business
because 95 of people
are messed up in their head
thinking
that it's a tough time to grow your
business
and they're allowing what's happening
whether it's with coronavirus they're
aligning whatever's happening with their
governments or their local marketplaces
to control their thinking and their
emotions and right now
people are buying even when you think
that they're not
i can tell you this because i work with
a group of entrepreneurs all right
privately that pay me a lot of money and
every single one of them has weathered
the storm that we've been in for the
last 12 months and they're making money
so
the question for you is what's really in
your way is it possible that you are in
your way your mindset or the feelings
you have about what's going on how many
of you are doing better right now uh
right now how many of you are doing
better right now
and how many of you are still buying
stuff because you need it or want it so
heck yeah right people are buying like
crazy right now when people are stressed
they buy more when people are not
stressed they buy now here's something
that i want you to be closely
paying attention to
whatever it is that you believe is
holding you back if you did not or have
not
focused on
being an adaptationist
if you did not or are not focusing on
being an adaptationist
then you are falling behind because
right now there is more change happening
in the world and in the world of
business specifically than we've had
change in the last 20 years even through
all of the other recessions
all right we didn't have as many changes
as we have right now and
with the online world
okay giving us access to each other
whether it's on facebook instagram
linkedin youtube clubhouse etc
we have the ability to adapt and shift
but the
adaptation mindset is what you need to
do first when we are focusing on the
negativity of what's happening out there
then we are affecting what's happening
in here so when we focus number one on
being an adaptationist that i will adapt
to whatever the circumstances are out
there and we ask ourselves a question
what has to happen in order for me to
double or triple my income in the next
12 months here's the question that i
want you to ask yourself
okay so are there
you know seven and a half almost eight
billion humans on the planet
yes
are there people who could benefit from
my product or service that i don't even
know right now but they're looking for
my product or service yes or no
yes
is it possible that if i adapt and shift
then i can find those people
online or offline if that's what my
focus is if
i adapted
and found the people who are also
looking for me online or offline could
you double or triple your income this
year if you focus just on that
do you believe
that if you are committed not interested
but if you are committed to achieve any
goal health wealth relations career
business
travel money
public speaking bill whatever any write
a book
do you agree that if you're committed
you can find an answer if you're
committed you will find an answer
if you're interested you'll find excuses
and reasons why you can't so why not
just say i'm committed to stopping
procrastination i'm committed to finding
an answer i'm committed to solving this
i'm committed to upgrading my knowledge
i'm committed to upgrading my skills i'm
committed to changing my beliefs i'm
committed to letting go of disempowering
habits i'm committed to do whatever it
takes honestly ethically professionally
i'm committed i'm a committed person to
achieve goals not a committed person to
have goals
i'm a goal achiever not a goal setter
of course we do both right whenever i
want to create anything whether it's my
physical body a home a car a trip
there's a big part of our brain called
the occipital lobe back of our brain
even when light comes in through our
eyes right cells in the back of our
brain activate and an image pops up in
our brain
and that image that pops up into our
brain is connected to the motivational
center and the thinking center part of
our brain
so if a negative image pops up we reduce
our motivation and we don't take action
and then we reinforce that pattern but
let's say i have
a an image of something that i really
want something that inspires me that as
soon as i pop up that image in my brain
i actually release dopamine
okay
the reward neurochemical in my brain
that actually creates motivation that's
actually tied to what i call as the
einstein part of the part of the brain
that can actually help you figure out
how to achieve that thing
and so i create
images of what is it that i want to
create for health wealth relations
career business charity fun and
experiences so that i can activate
the reward circuits in my brain the
motivational circuits in my brain the
thinking centers of my brain to help me
figure out how to achieve it but the
other purpose of a vision board is to
give your brain the instruction of this
is the stuff that's important to me that
i want to create do be have or give
right so you know we all have you know
50 000 thoughts a day we all have so
much on the social media whether it's
facebook or instagram or youtube or
clubhouse or whatever all the different
you know stations and channels are and
the people that want to gather our
attention well why don't we become
better at focusing our attention on what
we want to trade our life for i
started to retrain my brain at 19 years
old and it opened up the world of
success to me in health wealth
relationships career business
fun experiences
and then i started to teach it to my
employees
and
you know in re max back in 1992 i hit a
wonderful plateau where i hit you know
1.2 billion dollars in sales if you go
well that's great i said but that wasn't
the ceiling for what our possibilities
were and so no matter how much i trained
our real estate agent had a thousand
five hundred of them or we grew two
thousand five i may have maybe a
thousand two hundred at the time but we
we stopped teaching them how to sell
more real estate
and we started working on retraining
their brains retraining their financial
setboin retraining their expectancy
point retraining how they thought about
prospecting retraining how they thought
about doing the high income and the high
impact activities and over the course of
the next four years we increased our
sales by 3.3
billion dollars
you what
increased our sales
by
3.3
billion dollars to four and a half
billion a year in sales
why
because we reset
the agent's expectancy point the average
real estate agent at the time was making
about 30 40 000 a year in the industry
our agent's average was
128 thousand dollars per person average
and i'm going back i'm going back quite
a while
yeah and then i did the same thing with
bamboo.com and we grew that from six
people to 1500 in 14 months to 10
million a month in revenue in the ninth
month and did a successful ipo on nasdaq
it wasn't because we were the smartest
kids on the block
but we trained our team to think at a
higher level to be able to overcome the
doubts and the fears and the anxieties
that hold most people back so what's i
am
when we understand that
from a brain perspective and from a
human being perspective and having more
control and being empowered
what gives us more control and more
empowerment
and the answer is awareness yes
awareness gives us choice choice gives
us freedom so i developed inner size and
the whole series of inner sizes to give
you that awareness and choice and
freedom so inner size one is take six
com the circuit so that you're in the
calm and now you can respond instead of
react
and then aya which is the second inner
size is around awareness so the question
is awareness of what and the answer is
if you can get calm first and then
be aware of your thoughts
feelings
sensations emotions and behaviors
thoughts feelings sensations emotions
and behaviors and you must do this
no blame
no shame
no guilt no justification
no blame no shame no guilt no
justification just pure awareness
in a calm responsive state and so let's
say you have a disempowering thought or
emotion or feeling or sensation or
behavior
you ask yourself what's my intention
well my intention is to be confident
my intention is to actually take action
because i want to achieve that goal
my intention is to meet him to meet her
to do this to start my business to write
my book to to invest in that whatever
the intention that's my intention
and then you ask so what's one
little
action step i can take towards that
now what's five what's one why
why one we talked about this earlier you
know when we think of all the things
that we need to do then that puts us in
it puts us back into frankenstein
frankenstein gets activated again and
then guess what we do we're repeating
that cycle so what we want to do is
interrupt the cycle
be more mindful which just means be more
aware
and then choose an intention do i still
want to achieve that goal in health
wealth relationships career business
finance whatever it is yeah i do i
really do i really want to in a calm
state i can do that in a reactive state
i can't
yes so i want to be calm first and then
in that calm state what's one thing that
i can do
now of interrupt now i've become more
aware
now i'm interrupting disempowering
beliefs thoughts habits emotions
behaviors now i'm gaining confidence and
certainty by taking one step because now
i'm building a
new neural muscle of confidence yes i'm
building a i'm reinforcing a muscle of
awareness i'm reinforcing my intention
muscle i'm reinforcing my behavioral
muscle now who's in control
me and the more i learn that i can be in
control regardless of thoughts emotions
feelings behaviors uh what's happening
internally of me or external uh of me
now i'm powered yeah and in an empowered
state i get done how do you start to
change your money story first part is
awareness see
if you're not aware
you cannot change it
so first you have to be aware and i want
you all to to to practice something for
today okay
i want you to practice this ready
practice being aware of your thoughts
practice being aware of your emotions
and your feelings
practice being aware of what you're
doing
but i want you to practice in this way
don't blame yourself
don't shame yourself
don't
justify why
and don't feel guilty okay no blame no
shame no justification no guilt just
awareness
once you are aware
then you can make a decision a choice to
change so
if you're aware of your limiting beliefs
write them down if you're aware of your
empowering beliefs write them down if
you're aware of your disempowering
emotions around money write them down
be aware of the choices that you make uh
in your tipping in the food choices you
make when you're in a restaurant in the
clothes that you buy in the
and again no blame no shame no guilt no
justification just awareness
then
here's the game
i want you to write out just begin
writing out a new money story
and i want you to do this
start off your new money story like this
i'm so grateful and happy for the fact
that
i am now
and and fill in the blanks feeling doing
experiencing having giving just write
out a little story of your money story
and then what i want you to do every day
for the next just seven days seven days
for five minutes i want you to read that
new money story
even though it's not real right now and
then i want to just imagine what would
it be like
if this was real right now what would it
be like and i want you to feel that just
use that as step one
and see what happens
what will happen is you're gonna do two
things i'm gonna get excited which is
great but you also may hear this little
voice that says that's not true you're
not this you can't that and i want you
to be aware of it without judging it
blaming it shaming it or justifying it
just be aware of it and go holy mackerel
listen to that little inner critic
that is trying to hold me back we know
that exercise can help us reverse the
aging process right it helps in
obviously elimination it helps in
mitochondrial activity
we know that nutrition what we eat does
make a huge difference right so i'm
curious are you exercising and if you
are how many days a week do you exercise
just curious i exercise six days a week
for about an hour and 15 minutes each
day and i do a
mixture of
cardiovascular exercise and strength
training and ligament training and
balance work as well two days a week six
days a week how about you well how much
are you exercising if at all and if
you're not it's the least expensive way
to
reverse the aging process and to feel
better as well if you don't give your
brain a reason why like why do you want
to do this why must you do this um
it won't actually want to do the work so
if you don't have a reason why it'll
take the path of least resistance and
come up with the reasons why you
shouldn't faster the law of attraction
is not
about
writing down a goal or a vision that you
have and sitting there like a monk in
meditation hoping it's gonna pop in from
the sky and popped onto your lap which
is what a lot of people
misinterpreted in the movie and the
movie didn't explain
so the law of goya
says that in addition to
having a vision
and goals and the emotions required to
achieve them
you have to get off your ass
and do the right things in the right
order at the right time
so uh very simple example would be let's
say you want
you know let's say a guy is single
and he's looking to um
meet a nice gal that could possibly end
up in a long-term relationship
and he writes it down he has this vision
you know and he's got his vision board
and let's say he walks into a friend's
party or a restaurant or a bar whatever
it is
and he locks eyes with somebody who's
beautiful and she looks at him and he
sees the connection he feels the
connection so does she and both of their
hearts you know skip a little beat it's
like oh wow this is an attractive person
that i connect connected with and he
walks up to her and he gets down on one
and goes
will you marry me
you go what huh
it's the wrong order yes it doesn't
happen like that so
in addition to being clear about what
you want and expecting it to happen and
creating all of the peripheral stuff of
what it is that you want
are you
in or are you doing the right things
to make that a reality
and on this physical earth that we live
in
um behavior counts
what you do matters you can't just hope
and pray your way into success
or into achieving what it is that you
want that's awesome law of attraction
with action
well the last six letters of the word
attraction
is action
oh i love that
right yes it's not be a buddhist monk
sitting there on your meditative you
know pillow
uh it's be in action and here's what
most people will discover right is the
universe matches and mirrors
what you do and what you think and what
you feel yes so true right so it's a
combination it's really a combination
there are five things that you need to
get really good at
if you want to really win the game of
money
one you have to get good
at earning more money
and every day
you have to invest a little bit of time
ask yourself this question and this is
again if you're really serious about
earning more money how am i going to
earn more money today
and let's say you have a job
let's say you have a job you say great
how am i going to earn money outside of
my job it has to be a focus because if
it's not a focus
then you're not going to do it so how am
i going to earn money today this week
this month
number one number two and these are the
five pillars of financial success number
two how am i going to manage my money
better
too many of you are spending too much
money every month
and you are not managing your money and
you're spending the future
instead of spending what you have or
less than what you have so you can
really start focusing on wealth building
okay
so
money management
and creating budgets and sticking to
those budgets is critical number three
investing
one of the things i taught both of my
sons when they were very very very young
when i gave them money
let's say i gave them one dollar
i gave them a dollar and here's how this
went 10 cents you have to give
to other people or causes that you like
10 cents i want you to save no matter
what
and then 50 cents you can spend and 30
cents
put in your bank just in case something
comes up that you want in the future 10
cents giveaway
all right 10 cents save in a never touch
account or invest in a never touch
account 50 you can spend so are you
living within your budget are you living
within your means are you investing
even a dollar a day
to get into the habit of being an
investor why because there's you working
for money and then there's money working
for you and if you develop the mindset
of being an investor
over time the law of compounding
interest
starts to work for you instead of you
working for it so you need to earn
manage invest
fourth thing you need to learn is how do
i protect my assets whether it's my
business my home my money how do i
protect my assets that's a skill you
need to learn and then fifth one
is all around
debt
now there's terrible debt like credit
card debt that you're paying 15 20 30
or 25 percent you know interest that's
compounded
okay and then there's debt that you can
get to invest and you get more money
from your investments than the debt
costs
so you can borrow money at two or three
or four percent or five percent and make
10 or 15 or 20
and now you can make the spread so
that's using debt but there's also
getting out of debt
so there are two methods to get out of
debt one is to pay the credit card for
example with the highest interest rate
first and you knock it down
and the other way
is to pay a little bit off of each
credit card so you know that you're
making headway now psychologically it's
different for each person it's actually
a little bizarre
in the uh neuropsychology
arena
most people would prefer to master
disappointment
in
because at least they're getting
the
self-confidence that they could be good
at something
yeah so it's like told you so i told you
i would
and it's it's it's a weird psychological
phenomenon
where mastering disappointment
is actually
safe
and rewarding
and in a bizarre way you can actually
see why at least i'm good at something
and so i know that if i set myself up
you know to win chances are i'm not
going to win so let me master
disappointment so i have some self-worth
and self-esteem
and so we become
i'm going to say we many people become
because i don't want to do that
many people become so used to mastering
disappointment that's their only source
of feeling good about themselves have
you considered that you can afford to
create an
irresistible offer to get people in
to buy
your first product or service
now whenever we are dealing with
creating irresistible offers let's say
you're selling a pen okay you're selling
a pen
okay
well you can sell the pen let's say for
a dollar right but what if you sold the
pen
and in addition to the pen when you buy
it right now
you also get three videos on how to be a
better writer
three videos on how to take ideas from
your head and craft them in such a way
that people will be drawn to what you
write now a pen can be sold as a
commodity
or you can create an irresistible offer
by saying not only am i going to give
you the pen but here is some added value
things that you can use or need
all right
when you buy my pen now why would you do
that can you imagine why you would do
that
well the hardest sale is the first one
and here's the thing that i want you to
remember
when you trust a brand and when the
brand has a product or service that
meets or exceeds your expectations
do you continue to buy from that brand
if the brand exceeds or meets your
expectation
do you buy more from that brand chances
are you do so what does that mean
it means that all of the time and energy
and money that you spent to acquire that
new customer
you don't have to pay for that
acquisition cost
so
when
okay
when you
acquire a customer and you deliver or
over deliver
not only do they
keep coming to buy from you
but chances are
when they are so happy with what you've
done for them
don't you tell your friends or your
family
so now we have repeat business and we
have referrals
both of which cost almost no more money
when i catch myself procrastinating
or
you know feeling i don't really feel
like it i really don't feel like doing
it
i really don't feel like you know taking
action i really don't feel like getting
up i really don't feel like opening up
my computer i don't really don't feel
like doing you know one more repetition
in the gym i really don't feel like it
the law of little actions the law of
little actions
wins
so let me explain
when you have a project when you have a
goal a vision a desire and you don't
feel like it okay the i don't feel like
it can be because of a secondary game
we've just established that but when you
become aware that you're procrastinating
it doesn't matter why you're
procrastinating here is a little
technique that i use ready
i do one
little thing anyway
i do one little thing anyway why why not
a big thing
well if i can get a little win a little
behavior
do you think that maybe i start to
interrupt the pattern of procrastination
so when i don't feel like going to the
gym i said i'll do it later or i'll work
out later tonight i say i get that but
i'm going to take a little action anyway
what is neuroplasticity neuroplasticity
is the scientific fact that our brain
is plastic
right what does that mean it's not like
plastic like this brain
it means that we have brain cells
right so the brain cells okay there's a
cell
there's an axon okay or a body then
there's dendrites at the end right and
there's synaptic gaps in between the
brain cells so those brains have
potentiality and let's say we are told
that you're not good enough you're not
smart enough you're not worthy you'll
never amount to much you're too young
you're too old you don't have enough
knowledge you don't have enough skill if
those patterns
are created and those neurons are active
and releasing those neural chemicals
from a receptor or from a
ascending neuron to a receptor neuron
and that happens often enough that
neuron structure or pathway
becomes more solid just like
developing a highway system in a city
and the pathways that are active and
reinforced when we are
young become the default pathways just
like the highways and the roads that you
take every single day to go to the
stores you take
now if it's true
that our neural pathways are not fixed
but the pathways that are easy to run
across okay or to fire the signals okay
are the ones that are dominant
is it possible
to let go of the limiting destructive
disempowering beliefs
that somebody else gave us for the most
part or we experienced
is it possible that through
conditioning programming deliberately
choosing our beliefs
and reinforcing new neural pathways we
can
create new neural pathways
right
so
if a neural pathway can be created and
neural pathways can be deactivated
then why not deliberately unconsciously
evolve yourself
if there is real or imagined
possibility of discomfort pain
the break on motivation slams shut
and we start to procrastinate
so we have this incredible system that
can
give us this motivation the motive for
action to go forward but we have to
temper it
with our ability to recognize
the trigger and the sensation
in our body called a feeling
that the non-conscious processing part
of the brain that gives us this emotion
called fear
all fear is processed at the
non-conscious level of your awareness
and then gives rise into the frontal
lobes
of the feeling that your body has the
average person
that has not been trained
feels fear
and puts the brake on
and goes and retreats into what they're
comfortable doing
the successful person either
they may be genetically wired to
understand feeling fear and doing it
anyway turning their fear into fuel but
that's not the majority of people that's
why 90 plus percent of people fail and
stay in that position but you can take
that fuel that hypersensitive rocket
fuel i call it and utilize it to
actually motivate you faster further
than you ever got before but it all
starts with being
self-observing awareness of when i'm
uncomfortable how do i respond when i'm
doubtful how do i feel when i've got
negative self-talk going on
what's going on when i'm procrastinating
what am i fearful of one of my most
procrastination by the way
is done because of low self-esteem
if you knew how to get something done
you could do it highly effectively and
on time and you were loving it you'd
freaking do it but most people
procrastinate because they feel doubtful
they don't have all the information
they're procrastinating because they're
worried that if they don't do it
perfectly somebody's going to judge them
creating
irresistible offers
creating irresistible offers what does
that mean
well it means
that your greatest cost of acquiring a
new customer
is the first sale
and so
have you considered that you can afford
to create an
irresistible offer to get people in
to buy
your first product or service
now whenever we are dealing with
creating irresistible offers let's say
you're selling a pen okay you're selling
a pen
okay
well you can sell the pen let's say for
a dollar right but what if you sold the
pen
and in addition to the pen when you buy
it right now
you also get three videos on how to be a
better writer
three videos on how to take ideas from
your head and craft them in such a way
that people will be
drawn to what you write now a pen can be
sold as a commodity or you can create an
irresistible offer by saying not only am
i going to give you the pen but here are
some added value things that you can use
or need
all right
when you buy my pen now why would you do
that can you imagine why you would do
that
well the hardest sale is the first one
and here's the thing that i want you to
remember
when you trust a brand
and when the brand has a product or
service that meets or exceeds your
expectations
do you continue to buy
from that brand
if the brand exceeds
or meets your expectation
do you buy more from that brand chances
are you do so what does that mean it
means that all of the time and energy
and money that you spent to acquire that
new customer
you don't have to pay for that
acquisition cost
so
when
okay
when you
acquire a customer and you deliver or
over deliver
not only do they
keep coming to buy from you
but chances are
when they are so happy with what you've
done for them
don't you tell your friends or your
family
so now we have repeat business and we
have referrals
both of which cost almost no more money
the first three that she gives
are reason
and so
the first of the six steps in rewire
your brain is reason and she says
if you don't give your brain a reason
why like why do you want to do this why
must you do this
it won't actually want to do the work so
if you don't have a reason why it'll
take the path of least resistance and
come up with the reasons why you
shouldn't faster so that's number one um
second e or second step to re-fire is
engage
and she says when you set a goal she
says engage immerse yourself in your
goal and why you want to achieve that
goal and then get support from a group
or a mentor to keep you engaged as you
level up your knowledge and your skills
and your behaviors
the third of her re-fire to rewire out
of the six-step process
is
feel
and she said get your emotions behind
your goal she says when you get your
emotions behind your goal by thinking
about all the benefit of everything
you're going to gain who you're going to
become who you're going to be able to
help
how you're growing when you get the
emotion behind it and you engage and you
have your reason why the emotion is the
energy
put into motion
that is required to get the momentum and
keep the momentum going is consistency
across all of your assets so your
business card your landing pages your
ads everything that you can do
create that brand awareness and those
colors and tie it into your name why
well
there's something about our brain
that creates associations so when you
see my face and you see the colors of my
books and you see the colors on my wall
and you see you know our ads or our free
content
or videos
there's a consistent theme
around colors and our brain makes that
connection
across all the channels so when you're
building your personal brand
be thoughtful around what does your
personal brand stand for
then
what are the colors there could be
sounds there's a lot of sounds companies
use um sounds all right to add to the
color scheme to and to the theme
so when we are creating
any type of
messaging we want there to be something
that we call uh banner to buyer
consistency banner to buyer consistency
which actually is going to be the fourth
point so i'll come back to that in just
a moment so i see all of your colors um
yeah when people
when people
um our brain
takes snapshots obviously in a you know
um first it creates cells of recognition
and when our brain sees consistent
colors over and over and over again it
makes the associations and every single
color
means something different to somebody
else so i'm always looking for
consistency
around all of my content i know in my
particular case i didn't believe i
wasn't smart enough because when i moved
at five years old from israel to
montreal i spoke hebrew i didn't read
hebrew or write it but i spoke it i was
just learning the alphabet i was put
into a classroom with 50 kids
all speaking french and english was the
second language they were all speaking
so i sat there for two years looking at
the [ __ ] wall
and not only did i feel stupid you know
i remember i'm 55 now so this is 50
years ago i remember kids spitting on me
in the playground because i couldn't
speak english so i'd get into fights all
the time i'd end up in the principal's
office my parents would be called into
school your son's not doing well in
school he's having fights with the other
kids and i was frustrated and the
teachers didn't have time to work with
me on teaching me a language god i
didn't know the alphabet so i was two
years behind
for my entire
schooling up until grade 11 when i quit
i said enough is enough so i had
developed this
belief that i wasn't smart enough
holy [ __ ] where'd that come from now i
know i'm freaking brilliant and i'm not
saying that in an egotistical way but i
[ __ ] i study quantum physics studying
neuroscience i know sometimes i love it
and i can understand it but the point i
want to make is i developed this pattern
in my brain that i wasn't good enough
just because of my experience as a
five-year-old
and i carried that on for about 15 years
until i was 19
and i had a mentor
you know asked me why do i think i left
school why did i think i was getting in
trouble why was i working for two
dollars and 30 cents an hour when i
clearly could speak and talk and
communicate
um i said well they told me i wasn't
going to amount to much it's only if i
didn't get a college degree i wasn't
going to be smart enough to get a job at
a company and i wouldn't have any
retirement i wouldn't have any ability
to contribute i couldn't make enough
money to take care of myself my family i
believed what what the people that i'm
supposed to believe told me
so i developed this neuron cluster
around my own self-belief that i was not
smart enough and as a result of that i
couldn't do well in the real world so
what did i do from 12 to 17 i lied stole
cheated sold drugs did break in and
entries did counterfeit money uh
whatever i could to make money because
every time you couldn't so i figured out
a way i could
and then i met a man one man
who showed me that i could change my
brain he showed me that i could develop
a new cluster of beliefs that i am good
enough i am worthy enough i am smart
enough i can achieve what i want to
achieve i can learn and it's easy for me
i can earn any amount of money i choose
i can learn whatever i need to learn to
earn any amount of money i choose and so
i started at 19
doing daily affirmations i recorded my
affirmations i listened them for a
freaking you know two three hours a day
in my car as i was driving i wrote out
my goals i recorded my goals i was
taught how to create a new imprint
into my non-conscious brain which is
where your beliefs are anyway
and i started to re-pattern re-script
and reshape my belief patterns my
perception of what's possible and while
i was doing that
my mentor says great let's upgrade your
knowledge and your skills so we raise
your level of confidence and certainty i
want you to read this book i want you to
listen to this audio i want you to do
this i want you to practice one hour a
day on your skills so you get better so
as i raised my self
confidence
and my certainty and my belief in myself
and i developed some good habits boom
one thing started clicking after another
at 19 i made 31 000 bucks at 20. i made
151 thousand dollars 26 i started
building my own company and did a
billion dollars in sales four years
later
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want some amazing bruce lipton
motivation check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i don't care how much knowledge is
in your head if that knowledge doesn't
go into your subconscious your life will
stay exactly the same as it was you can
be the brightest smartest academic and i
say fine did it change your life